what is going on there citizens of the reject
nation greg ann i'm john we are here today to
watch the gray man a movie directed by them
russo brothers who do the avengers movies
and cherry and also stars uh ryan gosling
returning to the big screen one of my
favorite actors of all time representing today
and chris evans of course looking like he's
having a good time this movie has a hundred
and eighty percent on rotten tomatoes right
movie it's gonna get all million of those people
back on netflix can't wait but i'm excited man
it looks like a really fun action movie let's see
maybe it'll deliver just a tad bit more with some
good star-studded performances including that
honor day armist ladies and gentlemen if you
can leave a like i know you can that would
be so appreciated also subscribe click the
notification bell covering a lot more movies here
on the channel full length reaction watch alongs
where you sync up with the time code available
for them super sexy rejects over at our patreon
page cover a whole bunch of shows and movies over
there where the same tier you get the option for
reaction highlights and watchdogs included for
some exclusive content and the prepper team thank
you for helping us edit down these highlights
i'm excited let's get into action people
i like honey buns as much as the next guy i'm
not going to guide your eye out for whatever
you want some gum bubblicious watermelon wave what
do you say whoa he looks weird that swoop of hair
that de-aging born 1980 incarcerated
in 1995 eligible for parole in 2031.
i think the goatee threw me my name is donald
fitzroy and i'm here to commute your sentence
what's the catch you work for us who's asked
the c.i.a you'd be part of an elite unit
let's see our program you'd exist in the gray
agreement how long have i got to work for you
let's just say you'd be indefinitely useful
i know everything about this character now
exposition yeah i am on board as a ci slave
damn
so this took place last year
2021 is very important
he was just a wild rebellious cowboy
that was a cold cold-hardened c.i.a agent
i don't have a permit it's not that kind of party
it's an interesting choice to like
tune out all the audio in this room
yeah just focus on them undercover of the party
ooh cool guys scar our target codename dining
car is selling information that can severely
compromise national security please explain to
me why i'm talking to a sierra agent instead of
somebody within our circle of trust six
was in the region and he happens to be
historically good at the church that's a good
ham wakes in this this is a star-studded cast
it's almost as if netflix has disposable income
why am i not hearing anything
i'm picking up collateral
there's a kid near the mark
got code man shoot the kid
stand by do not stand by
he knows someone's about to
shoot him that one guy for the
wardrobe nice that was awesome
i like subtle [__] like that
wow
they didn't tell you who i am today they never do
i'm sierra four i would have sent
you out to kill one of your own
that's probably not gonna make you walk away
is it no it's gonna lead to a badass fight
oh ouch
if you're sierra who recruited you
when did he button his suit back up
same as you i got all the answers
because i'm telling the truth they're not
it's like a graphic novel vibe to
this that's a good way to put that hey
take this and bring the bastard down i
don't want it you drove the car michael
hey kids
i don't want no part of this [__] there you
go i took it okay you give him hell six ah six
is feeling some pain honor among assassins what
about pocket litter to get anything off his body
did he have anything on his person that
you now have that you like to give to me
that you just closed up and put in your pockets
carmichael's been calling we
spoke you should go without me
tell me what i don't know well
that's the problem isn't it
there's a lot of movie in these last 10
minutes i know it's all the movie all at
the once brothers to distinguish
themselves minimize their text
instead of the whole screen now there's a
big one and a little one context why is it
always the last stall al capone booth i can see
everything from here he blew off his ex-film
lloyd hansen is a sociopath he has methods
sociopathic methods so sit on him the guy
has a higher kill count the entire mossad i
don't need lloyd's stable i need him effective
this is like a 90s action movie with the sheen
of a modern-day action film mr c.i.a you devil
and the jumper cable to somebody else
i got an urgent locate and destroyed
give me a name sierra 6. that could
be fun the man's got some street cred
make him gone does the old man know
about this not yet head's a role
give me fitzroy's file we'll find somebody
he loves and squeeze do me right lloyd
have i ever done you wrong danny this
movie's in a rush to get someone i know
you were the one who lost the asset in the
first place and you couldn't get it back the
last person that pissed off the old man ended
up floating in the potomac if you like breathing
you might want to fix this
that's just the most assured
cool ass villain in his own mind
needs anything just a nap he's just so cool
calm and collected meeting me in berlin
i'm supposed to be in singapore not anymore
russo brother's kind of gone a little
michael bay-ish haven't they how's it been
i was literally about to say in the like pacing
and the money-shotting of everything yeah
remind me hansen how long did you last at the
agency six months five and a half so how's the
private sector treating you to pay as well as they
say or do you spend most your time strangling cats
who likes cats i like cats i like cats i like
cats let's talk about the mess your boy made and
judging by your shallow breathing and puckered
[__] i can only assume you know why i'm here
you know i can't find him because
his file doesn't exist but your file
well that's chock full of nuggets now i tried
to get her to smile but uh you know kids
like an actual selfie oh my god i'm
really loving uh chris evans so far
plane fight plane crash i want him terminated
come again keep the body in everything he has
on his person just make it painless what damn
ryan gosling was trained to
hear phone calls while in flight
that's smarter sneak up on the special
agents man we all just want to talk
this is the fireworks and flares movie
it's a mummy reference
best trailer of all time
is there a wilhelm scream in there
wow they trained him for anything he so in
the moment he's just like yep i'm grabbing
this and i got air here
this is some wild ass [__]
i'm like overwhelmed right
he's doing it do the thing do the thing
when you put your hands to your side
make yourself aerodynamic yeah fall faster wow
interesting
he dove choked him used the parachute yeah
sufficient jason bourne [__] is that is that the
big game franchise like a blinking just
cause just oh like uh yeah the games yeah
yeah that's what i'm kind of thinking of when
i watch this [__] yeah it's like cracked out
hello it's me where are you emotionally
they're my niece you hear me hold on you're
breaking up hello hello okay there you are
so many flashbacks well why don't you come
on in and we can chat my assistant will get
lunch you like sushi no i'm good i just had some
skittles you can give me the asset you stole and
i won't have to chop your head off headquarters
needs a scapegoat and his neck is just about
the right size he knows what business he's in
he lawyers yeah i immediately don't like you
six as well is pretty natural compared to yours
don't say peter natural to me it's an [__]
your boy won't be able to walk 10
feet without getting his head blown
and that dog is exactly what bad
ethics and zero impulse control will
there's a alt universe where
rob cordrey played chris evans
yes absolutely here's a photo of rob
cordray in case you don't know who rob court
bluff rob cordray yeah
okay six fits tell him why he's here no way
the cast gets bigger i am a niece that i'm
raising someone in the dc office has accidentally
leaked fitz's address in hong kong not your idiots
fitz is starting a mission in brazil
tomorrow which means you are going to babysit
oh so he's got a personal connection to this
little girl i like your tattoo what's it mean
the writing this guy's name in greek what guy just
a guy you know trying to get a rock up a hill why
they made them who made him yes the gods they
need a rock i just i try to punish him i think
did he deserve it probably you ask a lot of
questions you're quite the conversationalist
i'm gonna get back to work shooter
oh
i want to buy an audi something yeah just
struck me the remote system flagged at 10
minutes before he pulled up we can keep track of
her pacemaker from just about anywhere thank you
he's a very smart man the only family
i got closest thing to family i got too
maybe that kind of makes us
family huh this just got personal
music to set the action scene fine young hipster
look at those caustics
oh this is cool seeing ryan gosling just
like a full-on action sure you're all right
it's just another thursday you
should go to bed sleep peacefully
how up i got dry cleaning nine espionage
i could have watched the whole movie
about him in that little girl yeah
i was really enjoying that space let me make
like a side sequel this will be a minute
i'm getting that i think you should go get
yourself cleaned up before we take your pictures
unless bloody and beaten is the kind of look
you're going for maybe it'll make it easier
to get through customs just what this guy
looks like damn wowie buffy is ken i know
this is all in service of his kenroll you need an
alias and it has to be something very very easy
to forget you can step in the world something
like you know john joe hon pablo is also a very
common name mohamed is the most commonly used name
on earth the desired response is emotion right
you know hope anger can you give a step towards
me please there's some hypnotic thing happening
yes i'm gonna trigger your secret training
emotional memory has staying power you know
all about notoriety don't you whoa what
the [__] what a great trap set up yeah
that's a legit trap door leads into a [__]
well yeah i never even met six until i landed in
bangkok and no one said anything about a retrieval
what's the asset do you know where six is no
macgyver
six is the last of the dirty half doesn't and
he is 100 conforming to pattern he hurts people
because that's who he is
that's here protecting this guy's so
unlikable i know am i jarring your memory yet
you can see the reflection in his retina
by an audio
he's just every cool action guy
let's put a very specific trap
where's the target where's my money oh
every skill in the book
it just so calmly hits everyone
i don't know it's a methodical
oh here we go
is
how much [__] chris happens is that
nice try pumpkin what's the issue are you
why you want my foot in your ass ah [__]
looks like an 11. who's this one wasn't she in
berlin i get the sense that travel time doesn't
mean a lot in this movie not the trunk get in i
could really use a comfortable chair right now
honored armist is so cool i know man she is
blowing up this almost feels like a sequel
to a character from no time to die unless
you want our names spilled across every news
alert on every phone in every pocket on earth
shut up and go sit in the corner too how about
that forget about the viking why are you walking
like that because i got shot in the ass suzanne
you're just an asset but it's my career my
reputation why did you steal technically i didn't
steal anything ford gave it to me then white
didn't you give it to hq no she gave it to me
they already had me kill an agent now it's
my turn how do you know you're not next
you didn't draw that conclusion get
comfortable we're about to get into
a car chase get comfortable like we're
going to prague or a jail comfortable
drones are a thing that we can use now because
sure where'd she drive over the curb for there's
someone in prague that he trusts the most who is
that that's your mother boring ah wow now whatever
i just did to your ears it's not even torture
i just made it up on the spot just came to me
not a bad strategy
oh yeah yes let's do it
i don't want to watch
should we try again okay fine i could do this all
day who's here i already told you i don't know
maybe we should get the girl back in here
he must legit cut something out of that car
scene you did say you were gonna quit it was
a life of few pleasures i clung to the ones i had
was three months optimistic if you utter anything
remotely sympathetic i will shoot you she
aged so much in the last two years i know a
whole new look and everything got a hold of some
evidence tried selling it to the highest bidder
carl michael got wind of it and used six to
take him out big mistake there's no way we
can copy the file it's a dead disk it's been
a while since i've seen a movie that's based
around action scenes yeah right how do we
most inventively get to the next one fast
like how he knew that that was there
where is he where is who the hell is she
doing oh no she's gonna blow you all away
he tried getting back in there to
save her well that was unexpected
did we just kill margaret cahill
the cia doesn't know what they're doing it does
seem like like no one's paying attention to
anything happening with them send everyone
get them in there every team light it up
this is one ambitious ass cop
not
today please just do it stay still
come on man you have my permission
to shoot anyone standing in his way
he's such a cartoon but he's so good make him dead
he's a hero
oh [__] now we're getting
some winter soldier vibes
sick of this margaret cahill wasn't enough
just gonna kill all the cops
you'd think
all of our teams are going to kill each other
just shoot the bus would someone mind
shooting the man handcuffed to the bench
now you got to get everybody
who he cleared out first
not bad not a bad gag oh my god
it's so insane
i love this yes thank you
extra 10 million to the first guy to
put a bullet in this kendall's brain
negative we lost him
nicely done there's a lot about this
that really feels like a video game
yeah or stuff you do in a video game
it's like time crisis i'm correct
yeah time crisis is like a random online component
so there's just maximum players and maximum chaos
damn it's nuts
oh [__]
oh my god
wow this is definitely the most
entertaining this movie's been yes
oh my god nice shot it takes all these people
to kill this one cool calm collected guy
that's how cool and calm he is he's just so
in the moment he's prepared for everything
clever that is a boss move the boss ass move
oh my god
and then just a crater opens
and the city falls into it
thanks
all teams report status this is quite
possibly the most spectacular failure
in the history of covert ops
the most
look at that just tracking the target
no change lone wolf get me that asset
what i do can't beat that dude looks very familiar
he's another that guy this movie is full of that
guys tell me in the comments who he is she's got
a pacemaker you don't have a handcuff key do you
he could do everything but
get himself out of america
sir figure it out with the paper clip i
just can't do it i missed lock picking day
i think he's actually a famous actor in like
international films yeah probably gotta get that
crossover yeah seriously tell me who he is not
in croatian we need a ride i call not trunk ouchy
oh my god
you made it more powerful choose me
just burst through a hospital window like that
the hospital window won't cut you okay okay
these drone shots are sometimes really crazy
it's like a amusement park yeah
you gave me an empty gun the shells were coming
you ran away and you need to say hey wait that's
empty i'm gonna bleed out while we have this
conversation i'm just gonna pack it and wrap
it and we can go how many wounded criminals
have walked into a vet's office in real life
i want a list you probably count on one
hand he started laying into my brother
so hard it was clear it was either
going to be my brother or him
so kyle i decided it would be him ryan ryan
brain fog so he was never really a bad
guy that's why you're not like all the
others bob we're spa
i do all right all right you got me it's
let's do good question you're 42 regular
knows the value of a good suit tell
me suzanne is there any other part of
your job that i can do for you failing
upwards does not qualify as success no
success qualifies as success if you're
you're a white guy failing out birds does
wow every fight scene is so big
the biggest that's not the only way these
people operate and do not pay this [__]
why they have all those missiles
and [__] outside the gate
wow i love it
give me eyes on the bridge
cool that's a really cool shot
you ready that is the
subtlest action this movie is
he's in the house they got really
excited about these hd drones yep
man make good edits
it's kind of crazy they got jessica hemlock
who doesn't play a tough person at all
really playing against type take this give
me a hand grenade do you understand me go
wow that can't be good for the pacemaker
99 of her character is a pacemaker
no don't kill her i like her she's a gem
you douche
yo this guy's the [__] man yeah
the best fights are given to this guy grace oh man
god even though slight flourishes his
physicality he also brings like a charisma
take it i don't care about the money anymore
these are not honorable people take it
interesting
i only do honorable murders i got a code
please don't shoot who could you get to my hand
of course one of these would be here
you need a good mage keep him showdown
i have line of sight you're gonna throw me
that gun or the little one gets a new face
if your strategy relies on whether or not
i'll kill a child you need a new strategy
whoa wow face maker you have been a
pebble in my shoe since the very beginning
and now i just don't think i can walk
away guess what i'm thinking right now
that you've over shared
my friend's gonna meet you at
the edge of the maze okay no no
yeah wait i'm not just gonna leave you here with
him it's crazy no no we're gonna take you with me
no problem this is just another thursday
go okay you got this now for some reason
six is gonna get like beat up a tad bit here
yeah when he normally would
but it's the final fight you
gotta have you gotta give up a few
or not phil might surprise me ah
do you miss your fingers still getting used to it
ouch
he's just a guy who's uh occasionally frustrated
oh damn this is reminding him of his childhood
prepared him for this moment
oh
finally suzanne a character arc
and you are
bad news is you'll probably get your old
cell back but the good news is if you behave
i'll let you out to play sometimes
he grew or something he completed
a traumatic circle sort of
we're just gonna blame it on the guy we hired
if anything ever happens to claire
fitzroy deals off i will comfort you
please remove yourself from my personal
space oh equality it's been unresponsive
the last few days he just lays there
can't tell if his scythes are medical
won't eat speed won't even look at us brain damage
he shows up on the skin starving himself to death
satisfied it's our official earmuffs song
started killing right at the right time
it's chris evans
twist am i allowed to chew gum in here
how did he know it doesn't matter he know
he's the best he knows the degree man
he can find anything i'm the green man
it's just over okay yep and you see he
had the dark gray pants but the lightest gray
jacket to signify his change all righty well
i'll be honest with you guys it's been a
half hour since we watched this movie so we
realized that this audio you guys can hear stopped
recording and uh about like an hour into the movie
and then we had to problem solve fortunately we
had some backup audio no it didn't sound as good
in the last uh half of this reaction because it
was literally like right around the halfway point
of this film but it sounds better than no audio
at all true and uh i'm still i'm still personally
recovering i'm like oh man it really like took
the wind out of me on that one i'm not gonna lie
it really took the wind out of me the last thing
that's last first impression you want to have had
as the credits roll on something as wild and
rambunctious like oh man the audio is bad yeah
it's like it's like putting a pin through
a balloon and just listening to it fizzle
out you're like oh but we uh we have to focus up
here and just give an honest review right now um
for this film which was i thought it was
entertaining i thought it was a lot of fun
um although it's kind of a mixed bag for
me you know it's definitely it's definitely
a mixed bag it fluctuates it fluctuates
yeah cause it's like the end credits scene
was kind of the thing that really like sort
of summarized my feeling on the movie of
i think they think they made a movie that feels
like that but it doesn't because when it's not
it it's weird like there's a lot of scenes that
just uh play just so it's so generic like it's
wildly generic i was surprised by this is so
generic and so straightforward in the kind of
movies that it's being like and that was probably
the quality that i was surprised by the most
because look what rocks about this film i think
it's really obvious what's great about this movie
the action is top-notch it's just [__] bonkers
it's it's wild it's insane was that prague
the big crazy one with the that they always
teased in the trailers that was in the
where everyone in the city all the baddies
come together to just kill everyone just have a
and here we go and there are even notes of
the purge in there yeah they're just gonna
slaughter everyone in sight they're gonna
have cool skull masks while they're doing it
uh chris evans was insanely entertaining like
he was he he was just having a ball of a time
i like maniacal chris evans um dinosh was kind
of a surprising scene stealer because he doesn't
have like he's not given a lot of lines but
he felt like such a highlight i think i liked
his style of fight scenes the best
because that's when it was just
like not all [__] like sensory overload and and
it was just so like brutal and well choreographed
you know i thought he was great i liked ana
de armas um i liked uh i mean ryan gosling he
he was really cool he was a cool guy you know he
weirdly pulled it off i'm not going to lie in the
first 20 or 30 minutes i was going not so sure how
i'm feeling about ryan gosling in this movie yeah
um but then as the movie went i think he made the
right choice of because he's kind of he's kind of
this hodgepodge of like a [__] ton of action
characters from from cinema and video games you
know he's just all of them and because he's got
that ridiculous cool calm guy who just kind of
gets a little frustrated from more like a 70s or
80s action hero yeah it was like he's a little
tired of this but but he's gonna get a good do a
good job and get the job done yeah but he's also
this like relentless force who's just gonna knock
it out of the park all the time yeah yeah with
like the most ruthless efficiency but also you
know like a flare for theatrics to some degree
yeah because you know capturing the kind of style
of acting that ryan gosling usually brings to the
table which is so subtle and and very internal
which complements very well off of the kind of
performance chris evans is actually giving which
is so much like literally mustache twirling
chewing yeah yeah he's just having so much
fun and they represent two shades of this film
so i think in terms of your main antagonist and
your protagonist i actually think that the way
those two chose to play it worked really well for
this film because his ryan gosling's performance
really started clicking for me i mean like in
terms of an emotional part when the first time
he's meeting the daughter um but it was like the
crazy action scene where it starts off handcuffed
to the bench he's just getting like a little
slightly vexed at situations you know and then
the way how chris evans is going like why
didn't one to shoot the one guy in the bench
like the way they were handling that was really
well edited and timed and funny but exciting
and and ryan gosling remaining like cool common
collected like pretty much from like beginning
this whole thing uh because you know it is playing
this it is playing this like empty individual who
has become so hardened and cold but it it also to
to portray an action character to that caliber of
superheroism yeah you know he he weirdly struck
that right note for me of i guess if you were
this capable in handling this amount of craziness
like you were just this skilled there's something
really humorous and well like this seems like
the believable way to have done it in a weird way
it's a weird way it worked it's like this cannot
be a real person yeah thus you cannot take it the
same kind of seriously you would in like various
other ryan gosling performances you could point to
regardless of how heightened whatever movie
is i i feel like yeah there he brings this
all that commitment but i think what makes because
i was sitting there too thinking okay is this is
this gonna be a little it's like there are a bunch
of movies you can point to that ryan gosling's
been in that would make you go yeah he could star
in a movie like this easily but this also requires
a certain amount of that you know like rugged you
know one linery abandon that you don't necessarily
associate with him but i feel like yeah it's he
applied the right amount of like he's clearly
taking it seriously but i think he knows the
kind of lightness it's almost like countering
chris evans with something that seems very aware
of itself but also still understated somehow yeah
yeah i think he was still in the he sometimes
because at first i was i was starting to think
okay is ryan gosling perhaps not in the same movie
that this movie is sure at first i was kind of i
was sort of in a playground like that but then it
started to like really work for me and when i was
like oh i'm really getting this performance down
yeah and he's got a lot of rhythm i mean for as
much as he is like there are way bigger characters
around him half the time he does have like a good
sense for the rhythm of this you know he's laconic
but there's also that fast back and forth he has
with a lot of people it's he's just as methodical
and how he deals with characters as he is you know
killing them yeah because he's not he's got the
skill level that seems to surpass john wick in
many ways um but he's got the he's got everything
he's got his spy human abilities he's got the
human strength ability and healing ability
and mobile ability of like a fast and furious
character yeah so it's like they took like a john
wick character threw him into die-hard situations
with the strength of like a
fast and furious character
with the yeah imperviousness to insane carnage
the fast and furious character has to have and
the insane like durability although i mean
he sells it better than half those movies
he sold it like i i really started to believe
like i actually believe this guy has this
like unstoppable lethal weapon and that's
the thing is you've seen this character like
a hundred billion times and you can see all the
influences but to his two yeah to his credit it
does feel like he does have his own personality
even though you can feel all the characters that
inspired this character yeah and uh chris evans
same same note like yeah just on a very opposite
side of the whole equation uh chris evans
really brought that i wish we did get more
scenes uh solely between them i would have liked
that just a little bit more scenes between them
and uh i i did like on a day arm i wasn't
anything like him and ryan gosling had like
electric chemistry or anything like that uh i
thought they played off each other just fine
and you know i really like ryan austin's
performance in the last half after that sequence
and then you know when he fights the news and he's
like super injured you know because he was just so
impervious to like pain it seemed like before that
i did find myself going oh yeah you know sometimes
in fight scenes and characters like this i like it
when it's kind of like an uphill physical battle
for them like like john wick or i think of like
daredevil you know those kind of characters where
it's just it is it becomes physically more of a
toll on them as it goes how battered can this guy
get yeah but still keep going but he never
never truly like leaned fully into that in
this movie and nor do i think they wanted him
to um i think because the movies is such it's
so it seems like it takes itself seriously in the
dialogues other than when they're going for jokes
um it seems like it takes itself pretty serious in
in the in the non-action scenes for the most part
these are serious stakes life is on the line but
it feels like cheesy yes in the middle portion a
tad boring yes um and uh but then it would have
like just ridiculous action that was just so
that it felt like this movie was constructed to
just get to the action scenes all the time yeah
totally well and that's the thing is then you
look at the rest of the movie and i mean i'm
sure it's there you know i'm sure if we go watch
it back there's there's some dialogue but like the
cia operation and just the organization as it's
depicted here that is kind of responsible for all
this it just seems like what purpose do you see
like these are like your own guys in different
ways that you're just sending after each other and
destroying like so like it did remind me of die
hard five at a certain point where i was like you
have destroyed terrorist levels of like property
here and yeah it's sort of like the cia feels like
a very small insulated thing rather than like this
organization that you know taps intelligence and
manipulates you know the country and the world
so it does feel like a cartoon in the rest of
everything but there's two kinds of cartoons
like one cartoon feels very intentional and the
other cartoon doesn't feel as intentional like
i think it wanted to be intense at times i think
it wanted to actually have an intriguing mystery
and an intriguing world and it never
did it never quite did like i was never
i never found it like intense and it was exciting
just by the sheer volume of the [__] insanity
of a video game it would become with its
action scenes um but in between that like
like to me personally i i generally feel
that you know if you're not gonna really
you you need you need scenes that support the
action or the action should support that and
here that's where i'm like oh man you got all
these great actors here this should be really
elevated and it never felt like it was like the
actors did elevate it they did like without these
great actors would have just been a doll fest for
sure yeah um but they did elevate it but then part
of me was thinking like maybe you should just
kind of committed to just a fun tone throughout
it maybe it should have just been aiming to be
solely a fun time throughout because i i saw one
wrong tomatoes capsule in the time that i was like
fuming over the freaking audio um because i was
like what did people actually think about this
and there was one artist i couldn't agree with
which was um this movie doesn't want you to
take some something about that i was like this
movie doesn't want you to take anything this is
like a positive recommendation uh one of the uh
you know fresh ones uh of you doesn't want doesn't
want you to take anything seriously i'm like
i don't know about that i think it does i think
yeah i think it does and that's what it would drag
well yeah because because of the way that it is
kind of torn between i feel like you can look
at the action as a microcosm and see that it's
competing with itself in being the really harsh uh
like really you can feel the physicality and it's
like all these like intense long takes and you can
tell the actors really threw down for the combat
training yeah but then the circumstances however
realistically they are portrayed in terms of just
physics and carnage are like so ridiculous that
they the two do kind of clash and yeah there's not
good enough writing around the real stakes or the
real motivation it's not a real it's not it's bad
writing around the espionage thriller aspect yeah
and but there is that thing of like yeah i think
the the grittiness of certain elements even though
heightened like does i don't know like i thought
they anytime you have somebody's niece or whatever
get kidnapped i think they want you to care
and and the part of the movie that was the most
endearing was them together well they have this
whole thing with like let's flash we do these like
random flashbacks that i saw on the cherry trailer
yeah and uh i didn't see the actual cherry movie
but i was like this looks like the cherry trailer
but yeah when they have a flashback of showing oh
my god this like because i was i was so mixed on
this whole thing with understanding six's past
of like cutting to it of why are we even bothering
to explore any of this to be totally honest i have
no idea why we're doing any of that it has
two recognizable actors and it's so heavy
like there's cigarette burns on on your forearms
and he beat the brother and i killed my dad it's
like all these like super heavy things that
don't really seem to amount like i guess
it's supposed to be i was i found myself just
questioning it of like i guess they're trying to
um pull back like oh in the beginning of the movie
we we had you fooled this was a bad guy but no
who saw that he had a he had a righteous purpose
i mean is that the intention because even when
it cuts to the you know he's drowning and he's
thinking of his dad like i i don't know what
this amounts to and i guess in the end he's a he's
a dad now this is just one is that whatever that's
what it is in the end right he's gonna be a dad
to her and now he's gonna not do what like i don't
he's gonna live a peaceful life and just people
are gonna follow them around the globe trying
to kill the both of them and he's gonna kill
everyone tries to kill that i mean it's messy
it's a messy film it's a really expensive messy
movie that um that uh i like i i'm not gonna lie
like i i i had f i had i was pretty much amused
from beginning to end other than a few parts
and i'm like okay this part's boring this part's
starting to drag you well that's the thing is it's
it's paced like a movie that wants you to take
it a little more seriously or not paste i'm sorry
it's the length of a movie that yeah you take it
a little worse but it's also like in such a rush
and i i yeah like i didn't really care about like
anyone or anything like it didn't really matter
not like nothing mattered you know it was
just about watching like cool action scenes
and occasionally being charmed by some acting yeah
it's like it's fun it's impressive at moments the
costumes and the locations are beautiful and and
yeah it's one of those [__] discover drones and
we're like we're using the great possibility just
looking look how cool this drone shot is my god
we're swooping and it's creating crazy edits and
stuff yeah i mean at times it doesn't even serve
it at times it's just it's kind of distracting to
me yeah and i mean i feel like you know especially
subjective arguments have to do with style over
substance but early on i was thinking like these
are really cool settings and they're fighting
amongst fireworks and there's like a smoke bomb
like there's so many cool and interesting things
that are like semi-motivated by the fact that like
you know they need this for cover or he's you
know got a lot of cool and interesting things
to fight with but more than anything they just
look cool and they're somebody they they feel
in the moment like somebody going uh what's an
inventive way we can have a fight scene now what
have we not done yet and so yeah it's like luckily
a lot of that stuff is inventive and a lot of it's
captured really cool like you said michael bay
and the first act i kept sitting there thinking
this does feel like a michael bay movie and that
everything is like check out how cool every kind
like no shot is not kind of informed by like check
out how cool and intense this is and and yeah it
manages to balance that energy with again the
really good cast and so it's one of those things
where i get it like it's a summer romp where you
don't need to take too many things seriously but
i think the things it wants you to take seriously
are going to be the factor for people and whether
they like it or not no i mean at the end of
the day most of the run time is scenes and
there's only and most of the runtime is not action
even though you might walk away thinking of that
yeah it's not most of the runtime so i'm like
well most of the runtime definitely needs to
be improved yeah and i'm shocked because of who
they have the entire collaboration of writing
and directing they've made some great films
and so to see that this is what was delivered
upon writing especially uh was shocking um in that
regard because i i really felt that once we did
get to that scene where he breaks out where where
he is handcuffed to the bench and all that like
okay this is great like that was really great and
then and and then it i thought it was gonna like
kind of like maintain this and go this is really
clicking for me this is really working because
i was just so intermittent for me of of really
enjoying some scenes and then really just not
enjoying like just going like this is just a kind
of a weird film that falls flat a lot of the time
no matter how bombastic it is um it would fall it
would definitely fall flat and i i i am conflicted
on my feelings uh for it because even i'm like
looking at raw tomatoes i'm like it's at 51
currently so it's like what 50 side do i fall
on and i'm like i'm kind of in the middle of
that 50 yeah i wonder what this would be like on
a re-watch because there's a lot that's appealing
the first time around but but i mean yeah you look
at marcus mcfeely co-writing this together and you
think this is also based on source material which
i i don't know how much has changed from that but
it does like the least interesting thing is the
actual circumstances of the spy espionage like
that whole opening scene where he's talking
to four and he gives him the necklace
you're sitting there going you know it's like i
thought of the born identity again in that moment
because it reminded me of the moment where
he has the face off with clive owen and it's
partly about it's a very similar scene with like
just way more it's the only time you even see
clive owens character in that movie or out of a
couple but it's the only like real talk they have
and it's the same kind of thing where it's
like uh we're both kind of victims of the same
that's not turning on you except you didn't get
to know the organization here it's like you led
with that scene instead of putting it like halfway
through and then we get to know the organization
but really only through this one guy and his
assistant who's annoyed with him yeah it's like
they they got to the plot so fast yeah they were
really rushing to it like insert insert cut around
while this person's talking you know i have it
overlapped to a scene that's already starting now
uh you know jump around through time a lot it was
just it was non-stop it just wouldn't it wouldn't
stop and then and i'm like well you can't generate
intensity without any buildup to it uh at all and
that's what kind of really sort of lacked for me
because i see a better movie and i wouldn't be as
perplexed with this and i would just walk away
going like that's a solid entertaining ass fun
time but when i'm here going man i kind of wish i
didn't know who was involved in this movie because
if i didn't know who was involved with this movie
if i didn't if it was just some random netflix
movie i watched i would expect to be sitting here
you know it's not even a thought i had until right
now but but i think that you know with knowing
this is netflix's most expensive movie knowing
the stars knowing the writers knowing the director
that i i've i would have walked away going
damn i should have seen this in the theaters
yeah yeah yeah or i'm like i'm totally fine
watching this at home and that's a bummer because
i mean there are a couple like that that skydiving
sequence or you know skype falling sequence
uh is one of those things where i was sitting
there going man like i can't i can tell there are
some insane effects and stunts mixing in and out
i would be fascinated to know what this looks
like on a big screen but at the same time you
complete the movie and again yeah you look at all
the resources that went into it and all the people
involved and you think or i thought man if this
had been a titan if this didn't care so much about
certain things and committed to being a tight 90
minutes or an hour and 45 even and just used the
the most essential components almost and played
it even maybe a little more simple and just kept
the action they wanted this could have been
that really satisfying blockbuster what the
dialogue scenes had like just fun rhythm yeah
fun characters yeah but at times it played a
little spoof-like because at times it's like this
that's why i said rob cordray because i'm like
this feels like rob cordray to
harold and kumar escaped guantanamo
bay like that kind of cia story and then
jessica henwick's just like always like
pulling her hair out and like losing her [__]
and it just felt like a cartoon in a way that
at times i couldn't quite tell if it wanted to be
a cartoon in those scenes or if it want to take
itself seriously because sometimes it really
felt like they wanted to take itself serious
and and yeah and then you especially in the
fbi or cia side of it you're like it's not
nuanced enough to be serious but it's also not
going overboard with the cheese enough to like
really be fun in spite of what it's doing it's
more just like you said it feels like a 90s
you know cia thriller character that's all
evil and all in control yeah and uh yeah it it
it doesn't amount but it is really fun in the
moment and yeah you make you kind of wish that
they had gone you know what the point is to watch
chris evans and ryan gosling go head to head and
clash those personalities together and let's focus
in on on that and there's plenty of that there's
a lot of that um i didn't feel like there was
enough but no it's it is that thing once we got
toward the end even as much as i don't have like
two scenes together yeah and as much as i don't
need this movie to be longer like that and by the
time we got to them fighting at the end i felt
like this in the order of events i feel like this
should be like the fight number two out of three
or some kind of thing or or if there had been
another scene of just the two of them together
talking you know intensely or you know bouncing
off each other for more yeah like they feel oddly
separate from each other for how much this movie
is selling you their match up well the thing is
the problem with chris evans is
character as much fun as he's having
he's the furthest from intimidating he's the
furthest from scary or imposing you know like
not you you don't really i didn't even feel a
build up to them finally fighting each other i
didn't feel like he was as good as they made
him out to be no everyone's just talking him
up but they also treat him like he's the biggest
dumbass on the planet and he is kind of a dumbass
because his whole plan is just like i got every
bunch of black ops assassins i could find and
i'm just gonna throw them all at the same dude
they're all gonna kill each other and the cops and
then i'm gonna have to go and he never really had
scenes that showed he was he was capable like they
kind of say like oh he got kicked out but it would
he got kicked out after five and a half months
um but i thought that meant like oh he was just
like too brutal for the cia like he was too
too lethal but it was just like you're you're
an unhitched cartoon bulldog or something like i
don't know exactly know what you are what kind of
asset would you be to anybody i guess other than
your ability to corral a bunch of other people
to fight for you because that movie doesn't ever
show you like why he i'm not saying why
in terms of like what's his backstory but
we don't get that flashback moment to be like
let's see a really good establishing scene of this
guy to really get us you know feeling the dread
or whatever for him that they want us to feel
like oh yeah he's funny he's there's something
really funny about him um but you know he's the
one who could take down ryan gosling i was like
danish is the one who took that right i was like
well and and yeah like that's that's the funny
thing is i almost feel like they were afraid
to make him too unlikable or something and so
he is cartoonishly unlikable fun to watch but
i feel like the key to a character like that is
often including one or two moments where they do
cross the line into ruthlessness and hate ability
yeah where you do see that oh they are the one
who is the one to fear or the one you hate
yeah or something like that but it was uh it
that's the problem with that character is because
honestly like with what the writing is i'm like
now chris evans did it the best yeah no i mean
for what yeah for what's there it's i couldn't ask
for more but also but there's a lot of problems
though with the way he's written that don't help
serve this there's no for a movie as big as
this that also feels like it's there's no stakes
yeah and and i think that's the biggest issue
with it is you got to have some stakes you just
got it you just got to have some stakes to in
any way yeah because once you've seen the trick
it's like i feel like in the the first viewing of
this movie gets by on a lot of whooshing and and
you know physical ingenuity like a lot of really
interesting like fun and crash bang choreography
and and there's a lot to enjoy on on the surface
there but yeah once you come out of it you're
like ah there's there's nothing really that you'd
want to revisit and and i guess the mystique of
the inventiveness wears off after the first time
you've seen it so what you have to come back to
is just a bunch of pretty good action and
stuff like that but there's not really a lot to
unpack or really you know dissect yeah i
have no i i don't really have an interest
in re-watching this movie no and i was like
[__] ryan gosling's returning to the screen
yeah russo brothers chris evans how did they
harvest like i i think you know the reason
you get a cast like this to sign up is knowing
who's directing the film so i i would expect
i did expect something that i expected to disagree
with that 51 when i saw it i expected to be like
oh you know i'm one of the people that just gets
it yeah just have fun yeah put the movie on it's
level yeah you know but very few know how to like
bring the cool action and then also keep the keep
a big life in between and this lacks life in
between and to know how how much light because i
can hear i can imagine somebody hearing that and
saying it doesn't need to be deep but that's i
think the the art of things like these is knowing
just how deep like john wick is not an especially
deep movie but it's got style and personality and
life and in between the action and it has just
the right amount of those things to make you
care about the right characters and the right
circumstances to feel the stakes yeah it's like
it's just enough and it's not more or less it's
not trying to be more or less than it absolutely
needs to be and it understands what it needs to do
and how and why and this has yeah a lot of really
cool moments a lot of really interesting and fun
sequences some nice needle drops and things like
that but it's the whole is not as great as the sum
of the parts yeah yeah it's cause like with john
wick as one example when you get to the action
you're excited like oh here we go whereas uh
here you're it's a different ooh it's it's like
oh we could finally be entertained yeah ryan
gosling's gonna find another creative solution
probably no problem for a minute that's the
issue with the writing of a character like
that and the capturing of a character like that
is you never feel like this person's in danger
it is that it's never going to be that hard
for them and every plot hole gets fixed by
you going well i guess he's just that good like
i've enjoyed the humor of why'd you throw me
why did you why didn't you throw me a loaded gun
like that's funny but that's more for characters
where you feel like they're in a position of
really being like they're they're going up against
the machine they're two people that they're going
up against all the odds in the world and i'm like
this kind of felt it's weirdly felt out of place
for these two to be to have that moment like i
liked that scene i thought it was funny i
thought i think the idea of arguing over
you don't throw it because that's such an action
movie trope to like you throw a loaded gun and
they get into the field but i'll maybe go yeah
maybe you don't throw a load of guns there's so
many ways that would go wrong yeah yeah so it's it
is funny um but it also felt like this belongs to
a different more different
characters in different movies
yeah clever movie thought of this yeah yeah
and uh it's like and if they had that kind of
tone where it's like he just keeps slugging
through life as as opposed to the occasional uh
right that's all he does to show
like ryan gosling is the is that
he's just yeah he's just kind of tired of this
[__] yeah throughout yeah like no matter how
insane or whatever is it's just yeah like a i
know i'm gonna handle it this is gonna suck you
know that's how yeah which is fun to again it's
it's fun to watch but it doesn't hold a lot of
a lot of weight and yeah like watching
those those sequences back and forth like
it's one of those things where i feel
like not every movie needs to be meta and
that kind of commentary in dialogue can get
obnoxious but i feel like if you are doing a
movie like this that does have so much troping and
so much you know obvious borrowing and homaging
to a lot of other movies i feel like it does
help you in those certain sequences and then
like i was if that bit with the bench hadn't
been so well kind of my whole sequence from
beginning to end was so well done yeah yeah like
i i had a great time with that sequence enough
to have the thought in my mind and go i don't
really care that i i i don't see how this would
work at all uh i i don't um i had a train and it
was going but oh that that's what it was is i was
sitting there watching that sequence and thinking
to myself uh uh i don't know yeah there's no way
i had it it's gone my articulate thought is
gone i don't know at times he was mr bean like
mr bean but capable like part of me was wishing
they just committed like full steam ahead with
this guy is like so unstoppable and he's
constantly cool in the face of danger and the
other guy is so maniacal like just go full force
with like he is way too extremely cool yeah and
like he just can't be touched yeah and the thought
came back to the thought came back to me is in
that scene i had the thought of uh yeah it's like
he is like he's lucky he's like no one could shoot
him yeah yeah yeah exactly and in that moment i
had to i let go of it because the scene was that
good uh but it's it made me have that thought
damn ugh it came back it's like fleeting again
uh uh uh say something and it'll hit me third time
um yeah i don't know i thought it was just uh i
thought it was okay it was like don't get me wrong
there are scenes that definitely warrant a good
uh reaction and a response and there are dialogue
i like ryan gosling's monologue about his dad
and they so yeah it was it was cool it
was fun yeah but i'm probably i don't
really have an interest in ever watching
this again so no that's what it is finally
chris evans is calling out why can't anybody
shoot this guy it's one of those things
where at that moment almost came apart for me
because if it hadn't been so well realized in
every other faculty i would have gone you're
trying to cover up for the fact that you have
created a scene where everyone's like no this
would be impo he'd be dead like somebody would
take that shot instead of all the other shots
and so yeah in the moment it's it's well enough
realized that i was like that's fine i'll let go
of it but i think that's for me a good indicator
of how a lot of this movie's experience is it's
in the moment you're like it's it's good enough
that i'm gonna let go of these concerns but uh
at the end that's gonna keep me from coming back
yeah but could care less about billy bob thornton
um hey he showed up he's good she's fine but i
didn't care about him no that's the big
problem like when he died i'm like yeah
of course he's gonna die it's pretty obvious
this exact scene would happen yeah this exact
thing would happen and because that's what
happens to this exact character and yeah and
i mean like they took me by surprise with him at
least one like one of the more surprising turns
when he does just kind of give him up you know and
there's more to that but at the same time i'm like
i don't feel anything here because i'm like i
don't know these people and then also they work
through it and it's kind of fine and they're just
like i don't know i guess that was the only thing
you could do and it's not going to actually hold
that much weight on anything else yeah yeah like
you wanted to have some vague movies now are
doing all sorts of things about family and it's
all about found family right now and and i feel
like they could have done that and they kind of
do but it's like you said in the middle it's like
i would have watched a movie about him walking
watching after this girl because i'm like
that's the only time it has as generic as a
[__] plot as that is like you know bad ass
lethal assassin grey man's a professional
care of little girl uh like you've seen that
movie a billion times yeah it was easily the most
engaging part in terms of like this is the one
thing one time i'm kind of emotionally latched on
to this yeah so then it makes you go like i wanted
to see either a movie of that scene or the sequel
where it is just the two of them well and then i
think it gets a little too caught up in trying to
be mystery revealing when i'm like but you don't
do a good job at building a mystery you don't
seem to care about that yeah i care about pacing
like why do i give a [__] about it's like what
they try to show you is oh he you know this whole
thing with the daughter the daughters like he can
be a dad and be the kind of dad that he never had
you know like he could do things differently and
protect her and this is why he's uncomfortable
around kids and i'm like i think that's what
they're trying to say in the whole point of it
but you you waited way too long to give any hints
about his backstory to make me go oh that's what's
going on you know yeah totally ah um it's a mess
it's a mess of a film and it could have been
great and if this was not the people who
worked on it then i would have been like another
possible netflix movie and i'm totally fine but
no i i i think i don't think it's unreasonable to
be like it could have been more it could have been
these are the same people who made [__] you know
winter soldier where they had engaging ass scenes
when there wasn't cool action and that would
have intensity this aims to be more fun and more
heightened with its action because weirdly even
though that's a superhero movie this felt more
ridiculous to me i was sitting there in the first
few minutes going like i feel like you you took
some kind of spy thriller but directed it like
it's a friggin marvel tent pole like everything's
gotta be like ratcheted up to 11. um yeah anyway
that's just my thoughts yeah what'd you guys think
leave your thoughts down below you can subscribe
if you want and uh yeah we'll catch you all soon
marcus the leech mark leach how you doing buddy
we shouted you out last month on a stranger
things video and i figured figured that that
we got another netflix event it's the perfect
opportunity then i started to think about you
buddy you because that's the thing man you're
such a sweet guy you're such a supportive and
creative cat plus i mean you're living in the
uk you probably got a sweet ass accent you
would be the perfect unsuspecting undetected
cia mole my friend because think about it
dude you know the ins and outs of town and
you can keep it quiet you can lay low that's your
cover but when the time comes you probably can
kick so much ass and the best part about it is
you're good with kids and as everybody knows
any good hitman assassin badass type if you're
good with kids it's like the coolest iteration so
dude i want you to draw me a picture of yourself
in your best like cia hitman you know like shadowy
past but not too shadowy i want to see your take
on that and uh hey i hope you're doing well uh i
always love seeing your face in the in the little
bubble that pops up here on patreon miss you on
agents of shield and uh and yeah just hope you're
doing well and we'll talk soon much love buddy